los riesgos inéditos para un país
invadido no solo se viven en los campos
de batalla estos agricultores de la
región de nikolai se ven confrontados a
los suyos
los dominadores inspeccionaron la zona
porque los operarios de tractores no
querían trabajar dijeron no iremos a los
campos hasta que recojan las minas las
bombas y otras cosas así que tuvimos que
recogerlas en los campos las guardamos
como recuerdo para el museo a los restos
de municiones rusas en los campos de
cultivo se suman otras dificultades para
el sector agrícola ucraniano las bombas
de moscú también destruyen lugares de
almacenamiento como el de mica ctera el
7 de junio y el bloqueo de los puertos
ucranianos del mar negro por parte de
rusia hizo caer en picado las
exportaciones de cereales y semillas
oleaginosas de ucrania hacia el resto
del mundo lo que ahora amenaza la
seguridad alimentaria mundial
one wing form hay 1400 millones de
personas que podrían verse afectadas por
la escasez de trigo y otros cereales
sports
la exportación de alimentos de ucrania y
de fertilizantes de rusia repercute
negativamente en el mundo la inflación
crisis alimentaria es especial y pnv
área este especialmente en estados en
transición en el sahel de áfrica en el
cuerno de áfrica y la crisis sigue
profundizándose crisis con heidi bivens
la onu teme un fuerte agravamiento de la
situación en los países que ya conocían
crisis alimentarias antes de la
inversión de ucrania y urge a que se
alcance un acuerdo para paliar la
escasez de alimentos con los 164
miembros de la organización mundial del
comercio rusia exige el desminado de
puertos como el de odessa como
precondición para el paso de las
embarcaciones mientras que quien ve en
el desminado una oportunidad para que
las tropas rusas siguen avanzando y
ataque nuevamente